tu peux demander à quelquun de m'appeler
quand tu sortiras du
[Musique]
BL mon bébé va naître avec 6 semaines
d'avance je suis né avec 6 semaines
d'avance moi oh merde je voudrais quand
même savoir où vous étiez ce soir on a
appelé tous les hôpitux il n'y avait
aucune trace de
rickyaniki on a juste menti une fois non
des centaines de fois pendant de très
nombreuses années si la vérité éclate
mon mariage est fini et si on engageait
un acteur pour jouer le rôle de
staniky rockard Rod le imitateur de rock
and roll classé X c'est un vrai numéro
très complet avec une fon de sperme
merci d'être venu ce soir mesdames et
messieurs ça me fait jouir d'être avec
vous c'est une très mauvaise
idée oh la vache j'ai arrêté de boire de
l'alcool Ricky est strictement sobre
vous vous rappelez oh c'est pas du tout
ce que vous croyez c'est que de la
piste je veux que tu admettes que Ricky
staniki n'a jamais existé salut miss por
staniki
ouais aussi Ted Sumer mon patron ravi de
vous rencontrer Ted j'adore votre
costume et vos bulbes mais quoi les
implants c'est nouveau non ce sont mes
cheveux on va perdre notre
boulon on se souviendra bien de cette
journée pas
vrai j'ai vraiment beaucoup aimé votre
ami staniki ce mec a une bonne grosse
paire de couill en titane c'est pour ça
que j'aiai engagé c'est génial vous
venez de dire vous avez dit quoi reditle
pour voir on doit pas le lâcher d'une
semelle j'étais pas là pour la naissance
de mon fils mais en plus j'ai laissé
Peter frton version porno lui couper
voilà c'est fait ent
in pour
pases Impe monsieur de quoi
parle ch qu'il
deexer paire dans
[Musique]
les